in this video you're going to learn how
to make over 100 000 pounds profit in
less than a year and pay zero tax see
i'm standing outside the house this is
one of the most run down houses in the
whole of the andover area it was in the
newspapers it was completely derelict
and this got snapped up by some of my
students darren and ella from delaware
estates they bought it for a steal
they've done it up and the
transformation is fabulous and i've made
115 000 pounds and paid zero tax and
you're gonna learn exactly how they did
it let's go
[Music]
i mean it just looks like one of those
instagram houses before and after this
is absolutely fabulous can't wait to see
the inside hey guys how you doing how
you doing good to see you come on in
amazing wow wow wow
this looks so good oh thank you so
you're living here at the moment then we
are
was it that made you decide to because i
know you do that a lot you buy a house
you refurb it and you actually live in
it why do you do that capital gains
right just to avoid the debt yes pretty
much and we get to live in nice houses
as well yeah exactly so basically if you
live in the house and you make a big fat
profit and then you sell it what's the
what what tax rate do you pay i don't
pay any tax
how much stamp did you pound this house
zero it was uninhabitable i'm
mortgageable so zero tax a zero stamp or
take us through let's have a look
so this is the
diner oh kitchen oh good
wow
amazing
amazing amazing going with a little
island kitchen where did you where did
you where did how do you even begin with
a refurb like this and deciding where
you're going to get everything from i
mean all the cupboards it just looks
amazing sit down with a pen and paper
and just pretty much do ideas basically
and yeah things and sketch away and so
what was this like before then this was
a wall across here right so this
extension wasn't it small kitchen which
actually had two sort of sections to it
yeah and a cupboard here as well
so it looked terrible it was run down it
was small it hadn't been touched in
literally like 30 years ago it was 27
years it was derelict yeah wow
i bet the neighbors the neighbors must
be going mad but this house just sat
here yeah there's so many reports from
our like local paper about how it had
rats it had squatters down the story of
a tree growing through the middle of it
which obviously there wasn't
so how much did you pay how much did you
pay for this house 165 165 grand yeah
and then you've you've obviously
refurbed it to a really high standard i
mean this extension alone must have cost
you a fair bit yeah i mean how much did
you spend in total on the entire refurb
125.
yeah almost as much as the house yeah so
that that does include the interest that
for the borrowing that we had as well
because you bought this without even
using your own money right yeah yeah how
much how much did the investor put in
165 to purchase the property
yeah they put everything in yeah that
did not cost us a penny to buy no that's
incredible so the refurb was 125 but
they included the investors profit yep
madner
300k total all in yeah and then you just
sold it just sold it yet for 415. right
i had six
buyers that wanted it yeah the first one
was in a good position so we could pick
our buyer and just said yeah i'll just
pay full asking price and i want it
straight away yeah so he said yeah take
it that was six days after it went
online and then you had other people
wanting to go higher yeah
another another chap come and said i
really want the house i've missed it
i've been away
and i said sorry it's so and he said
what if i give you 4 20. yeah
so yeah we said no we said we've
accepted the offer and yeah we're happy
with that so where are you standing
right now this was outside before this
was just bush so this whole garden was
just one big bush and there were so many
trees as well wasn't that oh yeah we had
loads of trees taken out it was a mess
so how long have you actually lived here
then and have you been in the hot tub
yet oh yeah we've used the hot tub and
we're always in the hotel
did you buy this then was it just
because you wanted it while you're in
here was it kind of also a little bit of
a let them see what life is like in this
house a little bit it was we've had
loads of different exits for this house
we've been blessed and we can we had so
many exits we could do hmo we can do a
buy to let we we're going to do a
service accommodation hence having yes
so you thought about keeping it and
refinancing it yeah yeah definitely yeah
that's our main strategy yeah but
there's so much equity so this extension
this extension this is what i want to
know because you guys are so smart
because you don't pay tax or anything
like that and you didn't even have to
get planning so what did you have to do
in order to get the permission to to
build this entire extension literally
just apply for permitted development
yeah which means you can do a certain
size and this is 3.3 meters i think it's
just changed actually before but yeah
3.3
so we didn't even need to do anything
like architect fees um planning fees and
time as well so yeah so what's the
process then of getting permitted
development rights what do you actually
have to do you just apply to the council
it's really really simple it's like one
form because people think it's really
complicated
splitting title deeds getting permitted
development absolutely yeah right it's
not and even that like the building
control that was just one form online
people get their head sort of confused
about it all but it's so it's so
straightforward when you've got a good
builder they can do still calculus and
all of that yeah
was it difficult to manage was it was it
hard work or was it straightforward no
this team was really good wouldn't they
yeah i think we hit home with this team
how did you find how did you find them
how did you find the builders so because
we live in andover this is our hometown
don't forget i was a plumber for 10
years i've got every tradesman under the
sun in andover so the other projects
we've done elsewhere we've got to
outsource yeah and over i just picked up
the phone and called called friends and
yeah people that i've worked with before
and said you remember me on this project
can you come and have a look at this one
yeah done a few in the area as well
haven't we cherry picked the right
trades so we've sort of burned through
the ones that weren't so good and well
your network is your net worth
ultimately 100 and while we were
planning the project we were getting
them booked in
so we're pretty good at project managing
ourselves now we were planning
everything how long did the whole thing
take how long's the refurb the site what
how long's the what's the time frame so
the refurb was six months and then we've
sort of been here for a while ten months
so 115 grand
in less than a year well it would it
would have been six months really yeah
it was done
you know if we didn't you just enjoyed
living in it for a little bit before you
get your money yeah exactly and we want
to move abroad as well so now is the
time that we're gonna do that so are you
gonna do the same thing overseas
we're not sure we're gonna test the
market there and see what it's like but
if there's opportunity you know you know
yourself
if you see an opportunity you'll jump on
it so we'll see right well let's have a
look at the rest of the house yeah carry
on i mean to sell a house as well for
415 grand i don't know if that's is that
average around andover is that a high
price it's a good price you've got
you've got to bear in mind what we've
done here though so i think it does
warrant that you've gone high-end
haven't you yeah yeah about some of the
small touches that you've done or yeah
about the quality windows even this like
the fact that you can open this all at
bay windows you need that people really
like that 100 yeah i mean the the
bi-fold doors the roof lantern the lvt
flooring we've got all electric rads
obviously a matte black kitchen
pre-finished outdoors we've gone for
grey
doors and windows which are like 30 more
than white just little things like that
we've really gone to town i have to ask
that i have to ask though what's what's
with the bike what's going is this an
ornament right ornament yeah right so is
it an actual bike can you drive it you
really can ride it yeah yeah yeah and
the port and the pool cues oh so this is
actually a pool table
oh come on this is nice
yeah so that's actually a full tank yeah
are you good at paul not really we'll
have a game yeah
yeah
yeah so that turns into a pool table
um the bike is just my toy so we've got
the room for it why not
yeah it's not a bad size house either
yes um come through here there's another
reception room
so this was an office previously we had
all of our desks and stuff in here
didn't we yeah but we dressed it to sell
so we pulled this out well the agent
said let's what should we do that should
we get bed in here should we leave it in
the
sofa in here we already have this in
storage yeah i think you made the right
call yeah it's like the comfy area yeah
and then you've got the second reception
room area of the kitchen yeah nice i
love this bathroom i'd stay in this
house just for the bathroom to be honest
i'll let you go in there because it's uh
so yeah this is nice for all the black
features
uh the l-shaped bath with the oak panel
you know
and the grey top concrete tiles i just
love it it just makes it so modern
doesn't it it's this stuff that really
stands out if the house was if the house
was a 200 000 pound house you probably
stopped wouldn't you stop tiling here
exactly but you've got to go all the way
i love the shower yeah it's got to be
done yeah and how many bedrooms is it
three beds okay so this is
the main bedroom
i've got two
cupboards there built-in cupboards his
and hers which is good for us when are
you expecting to complete on it well as
soon as possible really
like i yeah
we picked the buyer he's got a big big
deposit
uh they're downsizing
a million pound house so they've got the
money
and yeah they're ready to go on there so
probably a couple of months i'd say just
the conveyancing yeah we had a few
offers and we picked
her because she's got a good situation
so hopefully it'll be quite a quick
turnaround will you be sad when you have
to leave or was it really was it more of
a business
i think you'll be sad i think i will be
i've fallen in love with this house a
little bit where are you going to move
to where are you going to go to well
we're looking to go from yorker aren't
we we are yeah we're going to we're yeah
we're booking some flights to go and
look at houses there amazing so um yeah
i won't be sad because
it sent us a load of money and it's our
job and it's what we do and
how many times have you done this how
many times have you done a house up that
you've lived in and then sold it quite a
few now so four that we've done
continuously and then we've obviously
got other properties
if you did this once a year though and
made 115 grand every time yeah that's
like a good salary yeah for literally
just doing a house uh finally living in
it yeah organizing trades essentially
yeah that's what it is yeah exactly yeah
so this is our little girl's room
that's very girly
oh nice but um
yeah she loves it
it's quite a nice size as well and it's
got the built-in oak
what's it like having a five-year-old
little girl while you're doing a full
renovation in the house is it is it hard
work is it stressful i think because we
do this day in day out we just sort of
manage yeah um it is stressful sometimes
having a child at the same time but
we know why we're doing it all great at
good and
that's why we're in this house because
you actually said look we've done this
several times now and we sell them or
rent them out or whatever it may be i
want to enjoy it for five minutes so
that's why we actually moved in yeah
hence these other little things like the
underlay we've gone for the cloud nine
best underlay you've got yeah these
electric rads the fitted blinds and
stuff because we knew
halfway through right you want to be in
here for a bit how did you manage to
find this property then because i know
that's a bit of a stallion of itself
it's a famous house it's been derelict
for 27 years
what happened well this house i have
literally wanted since i was a kid uh
i've just always as we've said before
i've always been passionate about
property so i've drove past
100 times one day i was driving past i
saw a guy by the door and a little like
cut through through the hedges jammed
the brakes and reversed back quickly and
went and spoke to him
so i got out and i can't remember quite
what i said but something along the
lines of hi do you know the owner i'm
really interested in the house and he
like sheepishly said no you know leave
me alone or something or other and
turned around
uh of which i said something along the
lines of all right no need to be rude i
was just curious because it just looked
like it would make such a nice family
home and me and my missus and little
girl just love the house and i think
that's what
got him to have a conversation with me
where he blocked so many other people
off because it was actually his family
home from a kid his parents bought it
brand new yeah so i think that sort of
you know that sparked something with him
but anyway i got chatting with him and
got i think i gave him my email and
stuff and said if you ever do want to
sell it let me know and he said i've
actually had 500 offers on this house
over 27 years did you say it would make
a really good family home and also i'd
make 115 grand profit
and i wouldn't pay any tax because i'd
lived there for a bit well because i
think people were just going in with
offers yeah
yeah but you actually took the time to
listen to it yeah right and have a
conversation i've really learned to
speak to people and listen yeah and as
soon as i said that and and he sort of
turned around and had a chance said oh
well it was my family home i feel right
it really just shows the art of just
being able to communicate doesn't it
yeah because if you had 500 other people
offering on it over 27 years
and i didn't even think we'd get it at
one point did we we said if we actually
get the key to this house it's going to
be a miracle so then so then he was
interested in in in telling it to you
but then nothing happened for a long
time long he went awol for two years and
then what happened then with the council
well we were chasing him uh the council
were chasing him i was calling him from
unknown numbers so you could try and
pick up seriously foreign
when did things change then tell me
about what happened with the council
yeah so we already built a relationship
with the council and we've been local
developers and doing up old properties
and said to them we've had this offer
accepted and nothing's come of it what
can we do which they then turn around
and said well we're at the point where
we want to do a forced or compulsory
purchase
uh so let's send him a letter as well
which they did and i think that just got
to the point where they were going to
buy it or we were going to buy it so the
council was going to basically force him
to say yeah because illegally do yeah
because if you just neglect a property
it's a nuisance it's a public nuisance
isn't it the council don't want
properties with rats and it's an eyesore
yeah so you worked with the council you
worked with him and then you beat all
the other 500 investors yeah and bought
it for 165. and didn't didn't know that
we'd make that much money at the time
because obviously prices worked in our
favor they rocketed up why we were
having the conveyancing and stuff going
through so even when we got the keys
one of our exits was to put it through
auction like the next day right on offer
at 250. we did yeah as it was you can
just sold it straight away yeah
wow 90 grand just like that overnight
really but we really wanted to do this
project yeah so this is the single room
at first we were going to do a hmo so we
put in a single bed fit for here yeah um
so you really had your different options
open with this one we did we did to be
honest we were going to do a hmo because
of the hospital and then we thought well
actually it could be an sa as well
because of that
um so we were going to refinance and
keep it
but then we had it valued and then there
was so much equity the estate agents
were really wanting to have a lot of
buyers for it exactly so yeah we decided
to sell it in the end what um in terms
of i know you've got a lot of projects
on the go
why do you borrow other people's money
and use investors money just because you
can go we can do so much more you can
spread so much further so
we've got investors that want to invest
their capital because they don't
necessarily have time to do it
themselves yeah so they're happy we get
to do more deals they get the interest
back and it's sort of now become more of
a rinse and repeat cycle because we'll
do one refinance or flip it on yeah and
then move on to the next one so we've
built relationships over time now over
the last couple of years what was your
best tip for somebody watching this
about how to raise finance i think
what's done it for us is just sharing it
with people because we've shared our
journey all along the way and it's not
only like helping people but also other
people are seeing it and seeing what
we're doing and then they get in contact
with us and want to do something
together
so we've raised the finance from this
one but we've also got another deal that
we've got in weymouth
that we haven't put a penny in on that
one either so that's a 50 50 jv so he's
getting 50 and we're managing it all
doing all the leg work
and he gets 50 percent of the property
she's just putting the money in yeah but
then but then from your perspective
you're making 50 and you're not putting
a penny in yeah it's win-win yeah we've
got our power team down there that did
this house so we know we can trust them
that you know they're getting on with it
so it's well you've done great with this
one great finish thank you
i'm gonna say i think my car looks quite
fitting as well on your drive
so these are all your cars they are yeah
i'm a bit of a car what's going on you
got like a range a bentley yeah what's
this focus rs got m3 under here track
car yeah i'm a little i'm a little bit
car mad aren't i so how do you afford
all the cars or what's the situation how
do you justify
did you lease them do you own them no so
years ago i used to buy a car on finance
that i probably couldn't afford and
struggle to pay the payments and stuff
then i thought just get rid of all of
that a lot get rid of the toys invest
the money into myself or we both didn't
we into training and what have you yeah
stick it all in property get the
property to make the money now every
single one of our cars is just owned
outright nice and when did you do the
training when did you when did you go
through the training uh we started
december 2019. wow the academy so we've
done so much since then we really have
to pinch yourself sometimes though how
much you've achieved do you know what i
think like when you're doing so much you
don't really notice the change and
sometimes you've got like stop and smell
the roses along the way because
otherwise you just don't really take it
all in but yeah we have done a lot
that's been a big mind mindset shift for
us hasn't it to put the work and
appreciate what you've got as well and
it
it pushes you to go on and do another
one yeah and go again and like yeah it's
great having the bentley there but now i
want the new version i'm gonna have to
do another house together you're waiting
for it out of your passive income you
got it instead of your earned income
your own income entering education and
into the properties yeah then you can
spend it and enjoy it amazing well done
massive respect thank you very much
guys if you uh have enjoyed their video
you can watch their interview that we do
together where they talk about how they
started got a full interview right here
you want to see more videos like this
subscribe and we'll see you next time
[Music]